dude it got so bad at one point I was
downloading the different because
there's it's like you know how the tech
boom kind of happened in Austin the tech
boom bin happened in La so there was
probably probably like 40 different apps
for delivering food I downloaded
multiple ones just to steal the food and
delete the app I did that a few times
just to steal the food yeah you would or
order I would get it I would sign up you
know fake email fake name order a
delivery to you all the [__] that
they made me do I faked it all I saw the
instacart thing I just took I just took
someone's whole load you know it's going
to Beverly Hills take all of it doesn't
matter what's goody hot breadthiverse
welcome back to Hot Breath the show
where you learn comedy from the pros I'm
your host comedian Joel Byers and our
guest today is a mover and Shaker in the
Austin comedy scene this is a comedian
as we like to do here on the hot breath
versus help cultivate the next
generation of great Comics this is a
comedian pursuing his dream of comedy by
any means necessary moving from
Louisiana to Texas to LA to now back to
Texas in a new city
all in pursuit of this stand-up comedy
game that we love to talk about so
without further Ado please welcome to
the show hot Brethren and hot sister and
Mr CJ Landry hey how are we today we're
feeling good it's a beautiful day
outside it is the homeless are glowing
out there dude they really are I've been
in Austin a few hours and that's the
first thing that I noticed they were
greeting us off the airplane that's how
they were handing out headphones you
know as we got on the airplane yeah man
they'll bleed you dry out here dude I
try to be nice and then [__] there they
are wanting all my money dollar for this
dollar for that it's like a bathroom
attendant I need to go check my car
[Music]
yeah you do
um yeah I don't know I mean it's uh it's
a great City uh I the comedy is booming
I have lived in a few different cities
for stand up uh New Orleans I was I like
I basically just did a couple shows out
there uh this was like I started comedy
four and a half years ago so I was in
New Orleans for a minute did that I'm
originally from Houma which is uh it's a
town known for the TV show Swamp People
solid killer yeah um credit right there
yeah big one dude they know me uh we're
third cousins but no they uh now yeah so
uh then uh I did a couple shows in New
Orleans and I was like okay like that I
talked to a lot of comics and they're
like I gotta move like you know that was
pretty much the first thing I got was
like You Gotta Move uh and this was four
and a half years ago I've heard it's
kind of gotten better now they have like
a little venue now for stand up because
whenever I was there they didn't have a
single uh venue they had no clubs it was
just like bars bar shows and uh caught
up like bar rooms
uh and maybe like little box rooms or
something but nothing like a real club
or anything now they have like a actual
venue
but yeah so then I just moved to Texas I
got a job in Dallas and then I started
doing stand up out there
um
I got
pretty like a lot of like um
opportunities there pretty fast with
hyenas and like the clubs there
and then I was a year in to stand up and
I moved to LA five months before the
pandemic
bruh yeah
but
but the even the fact you were willing
to move twice like that like one take
the leap from a smaller scene into like
a bigger scene in Dallas I know just
even a small town was just crazy yeah it
was just weird dude that was shook me I
mean just outside of just stand up just
Dallas alone just shook me man yeah just
being like wow building millions of
people
whoa wow electricity well land that's
not completely flat and almost inverted
insane
yeah like this just like I remember
going to work and being like holy [__]
there's like thousands of cars all
trying they're all trying to go to work
they're all all this is happening all at
one like it you don't you know I've been
to other places but it doesn't hit you
till you're living in it you're seeing
it every day and you're like Jesus
Christ there's so many [__] people
here DFW 7.5 million people in the area
and that's double the amount of people
in the entire state of Louisiana wow so
that was like that rocked my [__] you
know and then moving to La I gotta I
just I I moved there hoping that I get a
job at this studio because a buddy of
mine that I moved out there with we
[__] packed all of my [__] in his
Fiat and drove all the way to La it's
two-door Fiat right that's right yeah
drove all the way to L.A usually the
gayest thing I've ever done and this was
to work at the studio out there yeah it
was a podcast studio
um oh yeah because then you produce
Jeremiah wonders for a while I did I
well I helped produce I was an intern
and uh at the studio I was also
delivering weed for that same uh company
it was speedweed they called it uh
speedweed and uh they didn't really it
was so weird it was a Ponzi scheme for
sure they didn't actually deliver it was
looking back I didn't understand it at
all I was like how do they make money
because they weren't apparently charging
for Studio space at all they weren't
charging anymore and then also they were
like delivering weed to places but they
like only delivered like a certain a
small little area and they weren't
really making money off that so it was
very unclear like how they're making the
money one time I asked the owner I was
like so how do you all like like you
know you seem like you know it's a lot
of rent money you have like a giant
Warehouse on Sunset Boulevard that's
where they did the Pod and that's where
they stored all their weed and I was
like man seemed like it's a lot of rent
money for this play like how do you make
all the money he's like ah we have other
business Endeavors all right he drove
like a Maserati I'm like she's not
heading up here but
you're this intern coming in like
where's the money coming in Boss no clue
I have no clue but yeah I mean La was
where selected that was five months
before the Pandy and uh and uh I was
delivering weed they sponsored that same
weed company sponsored kill Tony and so
uh that's how I kind of got to know uh
Jeremiah and hinge cliff and all that
crap and uh kind of got cool with them
and uh yeah I like helped record pods I
helped I know construction a little bit
so I helped build like Studio walls and
spaces and everything in inside the
warehouse oh
um so I was like helping this company
just like be a startup in like every way
as much money as I can make because I I
mean I really was I was applying for so
many jobs I I did the sperm doning thing
I told you about that and I found it on
Craigslist it was legit and then uh and
then I I did uh obviously like uber and
door now all that crap you like kind of
have to do and you don't have a job
and uh
yeah it was really tough I mean it was
tough before the pandemic and I was just
trying to get literally just like on
open mics or any kind of shows and I was
like not not getting anything going uh
much at all until the studio started
like helping me with the intern thing
and then Jeremy I was like oh let's give
you like a spot like the rec room and
Huntington Beach or whatever and like
let's give you like you know like hey
help me with like a couple of spots and
then pretty much as soon as he started
giving me spots uh the coveted [__]
starting like full-blown covet all over
and it was funny because I remember like
going back home and I uh this was like
uh for Mardi Gras which was like I guess
like February 2020 and being like
talking all my friends from background
be like yeah I'm in L.A now I'm in
[__] studio in a big deal I'm
delivering weed I get free with all time
talking to the celebrities buddy hey if
you want to call me you have to talk to
me [__] at my time you know what I'm
saying you have to set up appointments
hey hey and then I and then like they're
like hey there's this weird uh there's
this weird disease going on in China and
I was like what no like how many people
that's like a thousand people like oh
it's crazy and I just remember like on
the flight back home like kind of
freaking out about I was like ah it's so
weird like you refresh the page of like
Twitter and then like the numbers just
keep going up and up and up and everyone
be like what the [__] is about to happen
and then I remember uh everyone telling
me that that's going to be the last
Mardi Gras that that we're gonna have uh
for like a long time they were like
worrying about that because then like
the all the big events were kind of like
being canceled and then it was like uh I
remember going back to my first day back
at the studio in LA and uh everyone was
being like uh we're gonna have to like
uh sanitize all the mics sanitize all
like the the equipment and the chairs
and all the keyboards and everything
and uh it was about two weeks and then
the studio just closed down they ran a
kill Tony out of it during the pandemic
for a little bit that's the only show
that they had running out of there
and um yeah once that was done and uh
it was just over it was done I was like
totally unemployed I couldn't even get
uh on unemployment money
in LA because they're like ah you
haven't been living here long enough in
California to collect unemployment and
then I tried to go through Texas and
they were like well you already have a
California license so we're not you know
what I mean they're like I ain't [__]
with you boy you know so that was like
where and they just put me through the
ringer like ah you're gonna have to call
two weeks from now and maybe try to get
money blah blah blah so I was just like
no hope I was straight up and I still
tried to tough it out I was still like
no it's Gonna Last you know two months
and then and I was in LA like just
ubering postmating for rent I was doing
I would wake up in the morning and I'd
do instacart in the morning where I was
like going get groceries for people
and uh
I would download
[Music]
um
other apps to do like the lunches
deliver lunches and then at night I
would Uber and then they had this
illegal mic on Melrose Avenue it was
illegal it was this guy he was a former
Mormon pastor
and for somehow they call them Reverend
something Reverend Jones or something
and uh he was like this this crazy
looking I mean he's exactly what you're
picturing just a just a overrun [__]
degenerate looking former Pastor guy
hair all grown out beard he would uh
he'd be he'd be like yeah it's five
dollars for five minutes and uh pretty
much
I'll sell everything here
with the mic
[Music]
he's like I got
I got weed I got everything else you
could possibly think of he sold all the
drugs back there but it was a wild child
I mean it was a really good mic like
looking back considering the fact that
everything was closed down there was
nothing open the fact that you could do
a room where there's actual people there
and they're like ready to watch Comedy
and they're all [__] up on a variety
of different drugs that's a pretty sweet
crowd to perform for mics you know and
so that's the only mic that I that I
could do and I did that maybe once a
week uh well during the pandemic and um
and yeah that was I would dude it got so
bad at one point I was downloading the
different because there's it's like you
know how the tech boom kind of happened
in Austin the tech room Ben happened in
La so there was probably probably like
40 different apps for delivering food oh
wow and I would download
I downloaded multiple ones just to steal
the food and delete the app I did that a
few times just to steal the food yeah
you would or order I would get it I
would sign up you know fake email fake
name order a delivery to you all the
[__] that they made me do I faked it
all I even photoshopped uh my license
the different picture
and then you just have to do that once
though you just have to do that once and
then you know you get the uh I saw the
instacart thing I just took I just took
someone's whole load you know it's going
to Beverly Hills take all of it doesn't
matter during the pandemic they're
ordering organic it's not gonna hurt
them you know what I mean
how much was it would you say that was
probably like a 200 grocery bill and
you're like these are mine now it's mine
you just said you didn't get the order
where you stopped doing it yeah I was
like oh they weren't there
you just you just pick some dumb excuse
they don't they don't come after either
doordash they don't come after you could
steal a bunch from doordash they don't
care oh I stole a bunch from doordash oh
you would just say pick it up or they
said ah they weren't there they didn't
like come out or whatever
and here's the thing they don't hurt the
person the worse that it hurts the
person that ordered it they're gonna get
their food a little late uh they're
gonna have to reorder but the door Dash
they're gonna pay for it they're just
gonna spot them
so it's hurting these billion dollar
[__] Tech whatever the [__] that's
really what it's like who cares about
that would you order like a bunch of
food would you be like all right 10
pizzas or like no I wouldn't order
because I'm just taking whatever the
people though I didn't know yeah so
whenever so I'm just taking whatever job
comes my way so if they come if it's
somebody orders some you know usually my
go-to is like wings or something
something nice yeah
something classy yeah if it's like
expensive Sushi or something or whatever
and then uh yeah and uh
and hey look you know what I by any I
did my job I I I prejudiced it to only
white guys names I was like he's doing
fine in Beverly Hills too like yeah yeah
sorry Ryan yeah
he ain't getting your you're getting
your wings a little late tonight bud
and then uh yeah I didn't care I was
like it was whatever man I was going
through the worst experience I would say
possible in like modern times and a
modern civilization uh so wait finish
that word were you about to say
civilization civilization oh okay dang
it I hate that I cut that off because it
sounded like you were going Za like
you're about to say civilization yeah
so no but uh yeah so so right so right
whenever I got like that was like that
that experience I was just that was just
kind of telling you that was like my
rock bottom I was I was living on a
couch though like yes no so I was living
in a uh one bedroom house my buddy was
living in the bedroom I was I was
sleeping on a mattress in the living
room and um so right whenever I was
getting like rock bottomy I was uh I was
like swiping on dating apps and stuff
just really for hope I guess I don't
know just someone to save me and uh it
happened I actually I actually I matched
with this girl who lived in Beverly
Hills her parents lived in Beverly Hills
yes her mom was a Food Network chef
uh her dad was a uh he he was like some
real estate guy that like operated in
New York and he'd like fly to uh like LA
to like live but he would do business in
New York and his dad his dad was the
former J uh uh president of JP Morgan
Chase
they were like so rich right and she was
like Persian Jewish or something money
on money I mean their whole house was
like they had like gold and marble
floors and [__] and um
it was crazy I mean I I you know
obviously I was I was you know putting
on my best effort to do everything I
possibly could to make her laugh and
have a good time and she was great she
was a great girl uh awesome awesome time
uh but you know uh it was it was nuts
she came it was so funny dude she
actually liked me because she I mean she
came over to my place saw the living
condition I was in what was up oh she
knew it was up and uh still somehow your
boy pulled it out like I recognize you
you stole our instacart I think is that
you yeah he's like hang on these organic
grapes look [__] familiar we order
these every time and then uh yeah he's
so funny starts ordering all these items
you're in the Persian coffee
uh no but then uh so I started so kind
of fast forward I start working for her
stepdad huh at their house during the
pandemic because all the office spaces
are closed he was working from home
she's doing like Vlogs for Food Network
from home all this [__] right and I'm
like basically staying at her Mansion
end by real so I go from like sleeping
on like an air mattress in a one bedroom
eating like chips and salsa for dinner
to like
in this Beverly Hills mansion during the
peak of the pandemic by the way George
Floyd protests going on my streets shut
down because of protest I'm living in
Beverly Hills dude I'm like living in a
mansion
I'm playing go I'm playing golf
I'm at the basketball courts dog
it's insane I couldn't believe my life
and uh
long story short we start me and this
girl start living uh like I live with
this girl now and I'm working for a
stepdad and her mom pulls me aside and
she's like look I know your dream's a
stand-up comedy but that's a dumb dream
she's like that's like you could start
working for this guy and you could
really be making like you could be
making a million dollars a year in 10
years
um and I remember like thinking that I'm
like wow this is like this is a true
Crossroads for me I could like I could
straight up throw all this away and like
just try to chase these spotted Flappers
that's what's on the table that's the
only thing that's the only place that
book me and and then after the pandemic
that's the only thing I was really like
I know I got that or this Melrose spot
with [__] Reverend Jones and
uh I ended up dude I ended up straight
up telling her mom that I'm like I'm not
gonna ditch something that I like I've
already invested so like I was like I've
already like cut my family off I've like
already like you know what I mean
ditched friendships already broke up
with girls in Dallas to come out to LA
like I'm not gonna just be like oh yeah
no real estate's cool now
so
she kind of took that in a way where it
was like disrespectful but I didn't
think it was disrespectful I just
thought like I I thought what she did
was disrespectful how are you gonna tell
me not to do my dream whatever so I kind
of got in this big fight with her mom a
little bit and then I got in like kind
of an argument with her and then like
that whole like it all kind of melted
down she went through my phone she saw
these Instagram Likes His damns
well a lot went on no and so then I
ended up uh
I ended up losing uh my girlfriend my
place of living and my job all in one
day because I was looking for her dad I
was living there and like one of the
saddest moments of my life was a comic
friend coming like help me pick up all
my [__]
from the Mansion yeah and then I was
like and then I was having and then I
was gonna go and knowing that the only
place I had to go was this guy's couch
because I lost my other place that I was
sleep in the living room that guy moved
away he moved back to Texas because he
was like [__] L.A so I only had this
guy's couch who was a former comic
friend of mine
so yeah and then I ended up living with
a couple door guys at the store uh and
uh I you know tried to post made my way
through it tried to try to do as much
Uber and whatever I could but uh I ended
up just like my car breaking down and I
was just like I'm just gonna go back
home so I went moved back to Louisiana
for like a a few weeks
and then uh yeah I started applying the
jobs in Austin and I just started trying
to work and get up feature I did I do a
bunch of Feature work in Dallas and uh
and uh San Antonio sometimes so I just
started doing that I drove out to Dallas
and uh I got a new car uh thank you
Biden flex and uh stemi what'd you get
and uh I got a camera nice and then uh
so then I uh what was crazy was I ended
up getting more road work than like ever
I started getting like more road work
just because like the connections I made
in LA and and Jeremiah like started
helping me out and like helping me make
connects and stuff and he seen me go up
so he knows that I could do time and
like no I got jokes and stuff and uh
I I started like air being out of these
like random rooms in Dallas
I did that for a while like I like I was
like living out of airbnb's uh like it
was like 20 a night airbnbs they're just
like horrible weird rooms and a house
type deal
um I actually have a really funny story
about that you want me to tell anyone
dude please all right what is happening
right now
what I was like oh you moved to Dallas
you were killing it and then you just
moved to L.A and broke loose at a world
of trouble you're like I was doing
really I got into hyenas I was really
young in comedy was going great so I
wanted to reverse all of that what's
goody hot breath the verse if you're
loving this episode and all the other
awesome content you get here for free
then you are going to love our brand new
hot breath VIP list all you got to do to
join is go to
hotbreathpodcast.com VIP and you're
gonna get exclusive access to not just
podcasts but also other content like
unseen interviews merch drops discounts
giveaways and a lot more exciting things
and this is for everyone if you're an
aspiring or working comedian or just a
comedy fan that loves getting those
behind the scenes nuggets You're Gonna
Love what we have here at the new hot
breath VIP list so go to the link in the
description or join at
hotbreathpodcast.com VIP and I'll see
you there speaking of Comedy I've gotta
shout out the network behind this show
big laugh comedy they have been killing
it in the Texas comedy scene producing
some of the biggest shows live and also
podcasts like the one you're watching
here and even bigger news big laugh is
hitting the road bringing their best
comedians and shows to a city like yours
so do yourself a favor join their VIP
newsletter and get exclusive access to
not just when they're coming to your
city but also even more fun content and
even comedy news so all you got to do is
go to blcomedy.com
vip.hb or hit the link in the
description we'll see you there it was
crazy and I so I yeah and then I uh I
started doing these airbnbs and um
one time it was really bad it was really
late so I like checked in really late
and it was kind of almost a cut off and
I was messaging him I was like oh please
and uh it looked like a Hispanic lady or
something and she was like kind of just
sending me times and she wasn't sending
me a lot of like paragraphs or sentences
so I was like oh I don't know what's
gonna go on here I don't know if the
communication the communication was
weird you know I was like just kind of
like okay and then like 10 30 you know
like kind of that I'm like uh okay so
then I go in I have all my [__] in my
hands like just like duffel bag and a
[__] camera bag and I I uh I'd type
in the code of the door it's like a nice
it's like a decently looking house
there's like a lot of those in Dallas
where it's like a suburb of like really
nice houses they all look the same and
they're all used for airbnbs huh it's
insane and they have like a little door
code on the on the door so I type in the
door code I open the door an entire
family
a furnished house with pictures on the
wall of their family a whole a whole
family is sitting at the dinner table
eating dinner as soon as I walk in with
all my [__] I'm like hey
and they're like they don't speak
English that well and so they're just
like oh why why is he about it they're
just talking English talking Spanish and
then I'm like hey hold it on my phone
I'm like duh Airbnb and they're like we
didn't know you're coming blah blah blah
and then it's like kids around and and
I'm just like this gritty guy is coming
off the road kind of drunk you know and
like ah in a room yeah they're like oh
it's not ready yet so then I have to sit
there and wait with all my [__] in my
hands while there's like kids eating
dinner and the mom like runs up to like
kind of get the room together and so I
was just like sitting there with my
stuff and uh I didn't realize that this
happened this is just it was all just
kind of hitting me like I can't believe
people do this for money where they like
that's some random
stranger guy into their house and let
them stay I go upstairs and I noticed
that the room right next to the room
that I'm staying is like a four-year-old
girl's room
yeah
I'm like yo this is the most bizarre
insane time of my life why would they do
this and I wake up the next day
it was so funny I wake up the next day
no one's at the house
there's not a single person at the house
the level of faith in humanity some
people have I was dude I stole groceries
for [__] dude I was thinking
like okay
refrigerator looks pretty full yeah
I was like whoa okay I wash my clothes
and everything and uh man just like the
the the pictures on the wall the family
pictures I mean dude it's
insane that just made me realize the
level of crime that doesn't happen is
kind of amazing so you didn't steal
anything didn't steal nothing good for
you yeah it was good I was good I only
I only stole whenever my back is against
the wall and I have no other options or
if you're Walmart I still I still stole
from Walmart yeah yeah yeah no Walmart
gets no
they stole from America that's right
still a lot of jobs that's right small
business we still are right back baby
that's right and uh if you if you want
to know uh how to steal from Walmart DM
me uh give you a little run down not bad
to steal without getting caught it's a
pretty good system what's the most
expensive thing you've stolen ever from
Walmart yeah uh pots and pans pots and
pans
pots and pans wow yeah nice pants
Skillet pans and you flip them no oh you
take them you could you know you cook
your chips and salsa with them of course
I use them dude come on I don't know if
you're flipping them on Facebook or
something no no no I I use the uh the
the skillet pan to cook my stolen steaks
that I steal from Walmart
by the way I buy a bunch you know I buy
all the vegetable all the all the
vegetables whatever you know but the the
high-end Bacon High in steaks hot all
that stuff
copped
all right we'll we'll slide through the
DMS
see what the that's my Merch this game
is yeah this is just tips and tricks
still from stealing from Walmart for
dummies
why did why did you leave Dallas to
begin with it sounds like everything was
going so well uh it was actually it
wasn't going as well as I kind of made
it out because I so I mean I was I would
I never even I hope I featured before I
ever hosted a club wow
um because they for some reason they
just wouldn't let me they had a weird
gatekeeper a guy who like only wanted
certain people to host the clubs there
and then the moment I moved to LA and
then came back and just had all these
names uh like Tony inchcliffe and Derma
tied to me and the owner of hyenas knew
that he just he just let me feature oh
great
um and it was funny too because I
remember my first time featuring it was
very intense because there was uh like
five six Comics who were like you know
10-year some I think one of them was
like 15-year vet comics in the back of
the room uh uh whenever uh and so seeing
their face whenever they found out that
I was featuring they were like what hmm
they're like really wow well good luck
up there you know and then it was really
cool like whenever I was done with my
set they gave me all the props you know
like it made me feel like all the [__]
that I went through in La was all like
validated in that point you know same
with getting this Mothership job dude
the fact that I mean
I showed up to potluck at comedy store
for every Monday you know paying [__]
15 for parking every Monday to do the to
do the potluck because you gotta you had
the what you had to so you show up I
don't know if you ever signed up for
potluck I'm familiar with it but break
it down so you show up basically you
park it's on Sunset Boulevard which is
you know hellish it's a nightmare for
any any kind of like parking or or any
long-term staying there
and uh you got to show up I think sign
ups at 5 30. you show up and you sign
you wait no a Disneyland ride line it is
like 150 people there same with here by
the way same thing 150 people and then
you it's and it's even worse because La
is like I mean it's just clown City I
mean it's like everybody who's anybody
who's ever done even thought of the the
[__] hobby stand-up comedy they're
like oh I'm gonna I'm gonna show up
they're gonna see me and [__] Gonzo
so it's like a lot of these like kooky
people waiting in line and then you know
I I don't know how they got there they
just showed up somehow in a tutu and um
I'm standing there in line with them and
you with the line is like an hour long
process you know you gotta wait for
everyone else to sign up and then they
do like a it's like another hour or so
until they put out the list
and then once they put out the list it's
like another 30 minutes till the show
start so you're waiting there for like
two and a half hours so that's why the
parking's so damn expensive
anyway so I saw I showed up there every
Monday to perform for Adam Megan to
showcase for Adam Megan that's the guy
who's in the back of the room at the
Congress store the town Booker who's who
watches every single person on the open
mic list to see if they're good enough
to whatever become a door guy which was
so funny to me that was that was the
that was the silliest thing about The
Comedy Store to me I'm like wow I'm
literally trying out to maybe become a
minimum wage paid worker here you're
paying 15 more than you'll make that's
it and then once I met the door like
some of the door guys at the store where
it's like oh you've been here for like
five six years working here and like you
really haven't like developed anything
as far as like a career in the comedy
it's like you're kind of just work here
and that's what you're known for and
that might become something else but
that's what you've like established and
invested years into of your life into
this thing that might not work out it's
like I don't know all that kind of like
um made me realize like oh Comedy Store
is not like the end-all be-all I should
just like not go there every Monday but
I did that for like months months uh on
in just like showing up every Monday
paying for the Bills signing up and then
whenever I moved back here and uh I just
I was like [__] it I'm just gonna do
Feature work in Dallas Feature work in
San Antonio I'm gonna try to you know
make a name for myself in Austin uh
whether or not Rogan opens a club or not
whatever and then to for him to end up
opening a club bringing Adam you get
from The Comedy Store here and then me
somehow getting the audition spot
to audition out of I think it was 30
Comics who auditioned out of those 30
Comics then audition and then get it
it was like it was the most like
validating like wow everything that I
went through was like it all made sense
you know like it was all worth it it uh
honestly if I wouldn't have got it I
probably would have
would have been a dark dark Road
not have been validated in that way all
the past things that I did would have
been so horrific for me I think to kind
of take in and process because I mean it
all happened so fast I mean everything
with the pandemic and the girl and the
thing it's just it all happened so fast
I didn't have time to process it was
kind of just I was kind of just running
like I was on fire you know what I mean
just kind of the next thing next thing
next thing next thing where it's like
now I feel like I've finally been able
to like slow down just work the door at
this [__] club and get up and finally
try to hone in on what I've what I what
skill I have up there so what you
auditioned to be the door yeah so it was
like it was kind of like Paul agree you
perform and then they pick who would be
I don't even know what the what the I
mean I know most of the people that got
picked for the audition were people who
consistently did The Secret Show at
Vulcan oh okay and the Secret Show like
I just did Kill Tony one time here and
then they got me on the Secret Show and
then ever since after that I just kept
like getting back on Secret show
um
because also Brian kind of knew me from
La whenever they did the kill Tony thing
in that studio so it kind of helped but
um yeah I mean I just they so I think
like most people that were either
affiliated with Secret show or knew of
through Secret Show uh got the audition
um but which is I think a pretty fair
way to do it I mean kill Tony definitely
cultivated like who's out here who's
doing good kind of people especially if
you get on Secret Show and you're
consistently getting on Secret Show and
doing well I think that's like how they
chose it
wow you know and now you're in yeah
you're in the mothership yeah dude it's
weird and that's the that's comedy Mecca
it is
it's gotten strange it's gotten strange
already it is I mean there's a lot you
know a lot of people that pop in the big
names you know they post it on Instagram
all the time it's it's a crazy feeling
it's a crazy feeling to even be on some
of those posts that's like another weird
thing
to be like on some of the posts like
where it's like Rogue and Ron White you
know oh like a swipe and you see that
yeah and then it's like me on there
you're like whoa yeah it's crazy but um
no yeah I mean it's it's also like
really hard I mean being around so many
I get I get real hard on myself what's
stand up I mean I get like I I'm I'm
like crazy with that I get I get
down in the dumps dude terrible like
what like how sad Joel when you bomb you
get like depressed oh so I made on the
couch let's have a moment yeah do the
bombs make you sad
they do they get me so sad I get like
down on myself like real bad about like
really just like I think comparing is
like the obviously like just the
downfall to every creative Outlet on
honestly but
yeah just uh comparing yourself and
stand up is tough man because it you
kind of can't really
um
you like can get better through like
inspiration of other people and being
like Oh I like what that guy does I'm
gonna try to do more like you like
sometimes can get a tool there or
something maybe to kind of transform and
maybe become a little better but
I mean there's some people that are just
so different that there's that there's
no way that I could ever be that you
know yeah like Jim Carrey for example
I'm sure whenever you know people are
coming up around Jim Carrey it's like I
mean I'm never gonna be able to do that
you know like that's like a whole
different world and there's a few guys
out here that are like that they're like
so different they'll work the door at
that Mothership that are like are so
different they're so like out the box
like you like just different just who
they are how they how they approach
stand up is just so much more different
than the way I approach it and it does
kind of get me in my head sometimes
because they do real well and they're
like beloved in the scene and then it's
like should I be you know it sounds like
your beloved though a little bit I mean
I'd say I'm working my way up there but
it's like there's so many good Comics
here I mean uh you know there's dude
Josh is amazing you know there's like so
many good Comics here man there's like
really good Comics here there's really
good Comics here like it's it's really
crazy Comics listening to this like oh
my gosh he knows Jeremiah Watkins
he's working at the mothership so
there's people listening to this like yo
yeah
but there's ever there's a lot of levels
to it you know of course you know that
there's like a level two and I guess it
never stops but I think I I don't think
what I'm talking about is necessarily my
like position I'm talking about just
straight my delivery and how good I am
on stage that's that's that's all I'm
talking about okay okay people's
progression and career but more about
your skill set on stage yeah that's like
all I'm that's all I really care about
is like just how good I am on there like
it more than Fame and money and position
of status like it's just like how really
good you are
and it's weird too because you kind of
other people admire different people
like I feel like some people admire like
a robin williams-esque like alts kind of
Comedy where it's just kind of
nonsensical and
maybe doesn't even make sense but I
don't I I respect that but I don't I
don't necessarily admire that I admire
people like um
I don't know I guess like a recent one
for me is like shangillis because he
just keeps coming here and just like
kind of resetting the bar for what
killing is I think in my opinion because
every time I've seen him it's just like
it's disgusting what he does really you
know I've never seen him live oh boy
yeah dude he did he did a sold out
Vulcan show here
I don't I don't think I've ever seen
anyone get so many Applause breaks
really
it's just it was disgusting and you
you've been doing it four years yeah
four and a half okay so he's been doing
it over 10. of course right yeah I mean
you know it's a marathon for sure but
what what kind of blows my mind is is
I've been around a lot of comics have
been doing in a long time and just how
you meet people who've been doing it 15
years and they still don't even come
close to what Shane girls does yeah not
even close not even a little there's
always outliers it's also just not it's
like it's not even just like what he
does because here's the thing for the
most part the guy's just standing there
delivering jokes
and they're not even joke they're bits
he's a master he's a bent Master he's
not a jokey joke like a mark Norman's
like a jokey joke Guy where it's like
next joke next joke which is kind of
like a delivery I'm more familiar with I
think my style is more like uh not
necessarily set up it's like a set of
punch tag tag kind of like style uh
uh whereas like Gillis is just he just
stretches these ideas out where there's
punch lines all throughout and act outs
in it and it um
man it's a beautiful thing just kind of
watching him over and over again getting
the chance to watch him over and over
again how he approaches every Set uh and
uh and just breaking down his bits as I
watch him over and over uh he's he's
like a he's an anomaly
he really is I mean I could save him
personal experience it probably took me
eight years to just figure out to just
focus on what I can control yeah and not
worry about what everyone else is doing
or yeah worrying about why this Booker
didn't reply or this festival or
whatever and just focus on well what can
I control I can control how much I'm
performing how much I'm writing and
preparing and things like that and
that's when I started to feel like that
that negativity or that self just
self-inflicted negativity all the time
if I let go of that pressure of focusing
on what everyone else is doing and just
like what am I doing what am I doing to
change how good I that person killed
what am I doing to be able to kill like
that yeah and just focusing on the
progress of that and just knowing I'm
putting in the work that will lead to
that that's that's what helped me
personally because I I feel you on just
like you just want to be there I mean
you just want to kill you just want to
be undefeated you want to be like an
Olympian that just can murder at all
times yeah and I just want to get over
what I really need to what I really need
to get over I think for myself is just
kind of beating myself up over the um
the
jokes that work and I'm sick of hmm
because what happens is like you know
I'm sure a lot of people that listen to
this are stand-ups but like
you know when you're new you're like oh
they got 10 minutes
I just gotta do that six more times it's
over baby no that's not how it works you
end up you got you got 10 minutes you
realize that's [__] three and then
and then at best and then you try to
write a new 10 minutes and you're like
ah that one's [__] you know too long
I should cut it down to five and then
you do like really hard and still I mean
I'm I'm at the point where I've I've
done 20 minutes I've done 25 minutes
that's a bunch I've featured a bunch all
like a lot and uh open for big names and
all [__] and then you go do a spot here
at Vulcan like I'm about to do the
tonight where I'm where I'm following
Fahim Anwar and you realize
what your a [__] is
what you have melted a room with full of
drunk people in Fort Worth that don't
know anything
sorry for it uh that you think is top of
the line top tier a is is really C plus
at best
and that's that's cold hard facts that
you got to swallow whenever you're
whenever you've been working at
something for four and a half years and
you think like you're kind of getting
onto something you're catching a wave
you're you're now you you think you're
you're somewhere but then you follow
Fame and Warren he's and I know him I
know a lot of his material very well
I've opened from a bunch I've edited his
videos for money whenever I was down bad
and
um I know a lot of his material I know
tonight he's gonna do brand new stuff
that he's like kind of working on that
he's been working on the last six months
and he's probably gonna bury me with
that you know what I mean with and like
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna like I'm
gonna get laughs I'm not saying I'm not
gonna get laughs but I'm but I'm like
I'm gonna be fighting the entire time to
be like hey I'm good I'm pretty good at
this yeah the whole time and that's the
that's that's what stand up is to me
it's just like it's uh it's fun I love
it but it's also like it's it is it is a
[__] man like it it's a [__] you you
will like you will take something that
you think is gold that works that a
[__] video that went viral and you're
like this is who I am this five minutes
right here this is my voice and three
years go by and you're like what you're
you don't even do it because you know
it's [__] heck you're lame you're
dumb they forever thinking that's good
and that's what happens yeah you do you
like straight up break down into like
just like
realizing that you're not as good as you
think you are
that's like most of that's that's just a
humbling it's a constant humbling thing
well you are as good as you think you
are maybe dude is that real oh God
therapy with Joel there's one way to
look at it though is that I mean it's
perspective yeah you could say Fahim is
getting these his A-Plus laughs but like
your laughs yes if you do something for
longer you're gonna be better at it but
at four and a half dude four and a half
years I was hosting an open mic on the
patio of a coffee shop for twenty
dollars and free coffee to like homeless
people I mean I wasn't doing all this
cool feature work open up for all these
people and like getting all these
amazing reps you know I was crying it
out drove 12 hours for fifty dollars you
know like I mean at four years what
you're doing is
for even for someone me being in the
game so long it's astronomical how fast
you're moving in this game so you can
look at someone like faheem who was in
the trenches for years he came up in The
Comedy Store just night after night
after night after night after night
after night how long have you been doing
comedy he's probably done that on stage
he's probably done four years yeah
that's a good point you know what I mean
so yeah you can compare yourself or just
learn from what he's doing and be like
yeah one day I keep I keep doing what
I'm doing I see what's possible and not
oh look at him that's for him not me
I'll never get there yeah it takes time
it does take time it's also the uh the
the [__] is um
I've realized a really hard thing for me
is uh
is is coming up with stuff
uh like getting inspiration for
something and uh
and you try it out and it works and then
and then doing it again and it just
bombs
it's I swear to God it's the closest
thing I've gotten to wanting to commit
like mass suicide just not suicide Mass
homicides
yeah I go dark you've got the hair for
it too I could see his mug shot I could
see your mug shot that is yeah
what I'm saying like this like whenever
[__] joke that I just did works and
then it bombs I want to go out like
Scarface I swear to God I just want to
be like [__] why
why it just did just work I just had it
and then it and then like I closed on
this joke and then you do it and people
are like what the [__] are you thinking
but it's not just that's for all of us I
have an anger problem but I'm just
letting you know that's that happens to
all of us or we have a bit that worked
forever and now all of a sudden it stops
working yeah well done does this happen
to you are you like over what the people
I'm like envious of are people who don't
even have the thoughts
the the people are just I'm great or
like I'm like they're just
they kill every set they like
self-esteem
yeah
people with just unshielded self-esteem
where they're just like yo I'm
the [__] I wish I had that I wish I had
a little bit more not not all that I'm
not saying that I wish I had like just
like you know I just you know no limit
of I'm the king I'm the greatest that's
ever touched the mic but I wish that I
was like a little bit more like I'm I am
good my jokes are good
I'm fine
everything's good but I have this
intense pressure on me and and people
tell me to stop being so hard on myself
but I literally don't know how I I just
I it's not like I'm actively wanting to
be hard on myself it's it's inactively
like trying to not be and it's tough
I I find it helps me if I focus on the
like the process over like the end game
so it's not like oh I'm killing I'm
amazing but it's like oh I'm working
hard and I'm seeing progress and I'm
actually doing the things I need to do
to get to where I want to be I'm not
there yet but I know I'm doing the
things I'm doing the open mics I'm
writing jokes I'm working on myself as a
comedian and focusing on the actual work
instead of the end result it takes that
pressure off
to just focus on well are you doing what
you should be doing to get to where you
want to be which is this amazing
comedian which me looking from this side
it sounds like you are yeah it takes
time I know the writing is so hard it
sakes dude this dude I mean I've
interviewed people 30 years in the game
who were like I'm still trying to figure
it out or I'll still that makes me sad
but okay hey I'm just saying you're
ahead of the game because you're already
there yeah you got to get well you got
to get over this mentality I think I'm
I'm slowly getting over I just I just um
I'd like to you know
I'd like to maybe be able to do more
like things that I respect like I guess
um like just more like I I want to get
rid of like any kind of jokes that I I
kind of like just over any like I don't
have a lot of sex jokes I have like the
sperm donor thing which I think is
pretty is is my grossest joke
uh it's really like a bid it's like
three minutes but it's it's you know
it's uh it's well crafted dude I worked
a lot of [__] hours on it I believe
you but I and it's Unique too it's
authentic yeah and it is and it's like a
personal story of mine and it's fun but
it's it's like you know it's um
I just want to not talk about
uh classic
topics that people talk about which I
think I maybe put too much pressure on
myself to not do maybe but because I see
Fahim you know if I I watch a lot of
female or female war is amazing if you
don't know who he is she's amazing yeah
uh he's so good yep
um but he he touches on a lot of like
topics that like porn you know what I
mean like stuff that's been talked about
a thousand bajillion times but he still
does a good job of it makes it and makes
it good so I guess I admire that too but
I just I I don't know I guess I'm really
in my head about the topics I touch on
and then like the jokes being like lame
or corny you're in control of that
whatever I know but it's hard to have
that gauge too because it's like it's
subjective really sometimes what is
what is kind of corny can sometimes be
brilliant to some dumb [__] in
Fort Worth sorry Fort Worth God damn it
I mean if you're Toledo if you're paying
the bills like you know if you're if
you're paying the bills let me spread
the hate you can do some of these jokes
to pay the bills but like when you're
out working out material you're working
on stuff you want to be doing more
that's a good point yeah I've learned
that too I've learned to have like a
road act something that's gonna work
because I you know I came up doing a lot
of like Hood rooms and I would do like
the race stuff and I would be the white
guy and it would kill and then I got to
a point where I was like I don't want to
be doing this so I just had to start to
kind of wean myself off of that and it
wasn't kind of like I ripped the
Band-Aid off it's like oh maybe I'll do
a few and then just do some silly
marriage jokes or whatnot and kind of
start weaving in that way and get the
confidence to step out into this new
kind of point of view I'm trying to
bring to this stage so it's it's all
incremental but you having the mindset
and the intent to do it now it's just or
instead of this sex joke I want to do
this personal joke that I think is funny
for me and start just introducing them
that way yeah because it's it's all it's
it's incremental yeah and it's been
tough too like of like just learning how
to I think I think I think what makes uh
good Comics great I started with uh
Ralph Barbosa I don't know if you know
yeah yeah for sure so I I was uh you
know I was uh he was like already two
years in in like one Funniest Comic in
Texas two years and whenever I like just
started you know so like I kind of heard
about him in the [__] wavelengths and
uh you know and uh just kind of like the
uh
just kind of like the myths of Ralph
Barbosa whenever I just started and
people were like guys really good and uh
it's kind of funny I remember a lot of
comics being like yeah he's good but
he's got a kid so he's gonna be [__]
and then and then he's like become like
a [__] Legend now it's so funny but
uh but like you know watching him kind
of progress like you know you watch
different people but like to be to watch
him kind of come up was so interesting
to me because he like he didn't do a lot
of mics
uh he wasn't like a mic grinder guy I'm
sure he had like a period maybe a phase
of doing that but he never from what I
saw was a Mike grinder guy
but every time he'd come to the mic he'd
have five new minutes that worked pretty
good you know and that he's working on
but he but I've learned like what makes
good great is like people who can take a
new idea and make it like a five six
right out the gate instead of going out
there with like a one or two
where you're like you should have ran
that by somebody or something you know
first before you just walk up there and
yell it yeah
and
so what happens is you become good
becomes great whenever you figure out
how to take that new idea and it's a you
know five six it's the first time you do
it and then learning how to make it at 9
10. fast you have to become like a
machine you know I've learned that
that's like kind of
that's what makes it good great that
when we're watching Ralph uh slowly
figure out how to do that was because
he's so brilliant man I mean for him to
for him to do different
um
it did a totally different set on his
don't tell
than his uh I think his Comedy Central
taping or his HBO he did totally
different sets wow so like that was that
for me was like oh you're like he's on a
whole nother level like where you're
he's so ready for the moments that are
coming ahead of him it's it's not even
funny you know uh so happy for that guy
though man I'm happy for you though so
thanks man I'm happy for you I
appreciate it you're doing good things
thank you y'all doing big things thank
you Joe I don't know what you want to do
thank you Papa Joe I sit on my lap come
sit on my lap this is when we get candy
you you do have a let me be your
neighbor
talking about I need to bring out a
puppet come on now come on CJ
we don't like the angry
the loving llama
[Laughter]
um but no yeah no he's he's great man if
uh obviously if you don't know
ralpharosa look him up but he's uh yeah
he's been a funny one to watch you know
he's just he was so young he's starting
to 22 or something like that 21. and
then he uh you know he had so much go on
with this kid and then he was a barber
he cut my hair two years ago
and I remember him being like what's
your goals for comedy and I was like oh
man it'd be just so cool if I could like
you know point to a house one day and be
like I bought that with jokes yeah but
that'd be cool right
he's like I feel that he's like yeah man
yeah you know he's cutting my hair and
he's like yeah I want like Ferraris
Mansions I remember him saying that I
was like ah damn that's cool and now
he's like doing it all right I remember
at that point I remember thinking at
that point I was like what a [__]
idiot
one of them [__] there Ralph
you're in a barber shop bud and then now
he's just [__] yeah he's just
insanely on fire are you on your way
yeah yeah but no yeah he's got a um he's
got a really good ability of he he's to
always right clean he was always clean
he always
he was uh clean for the longest I think
he's like started the curse a little bit
more now but he never talks about sex or
anything like that but uh I don't know
disrespected the [__] out of that I
thought that was really cool and um
yeah I can I like I have I have like I
did a clean Show recently forced myself
to a clean show did 12 minutes clean it
was fun to old people it was a bunch of
old it was literally just all old people
it's like a retirement oh AARP ARP no
kidding oh but
I don't know what it was it was some
weird like uh group that this lady this
comic out here uh Jen fullwiler she she
like uh
she like started this thing at Cap City
where like she just has like a yeah some
kind of community where they just want
clean comedy I see you want to do more
clean stuff is that well you said less
sex stuff yeah yeah yeah it's like what
are you wanting to well I don't know I I
just I I think like I don't know I guess
I respect Nate bargati so much I just
love that Nate over 20 years in the game
now he's still not Arenas and people are
like oh I want to be like Nate I know
people don't see him you know grinding
out of New York I know so you know I
mean it's easy to look at these people
and be like I want to be like that but
it's you know it's a long road they
earned it yeah for sure you're earning
it yeah for sure I just need to figure
out how to like stop saying [__] on
stage so much God I say especially doing
new stuff we'll make it your goal
tonight I know new stuff well tonight
don't say it I know new stuff I'm always
just like yeah and this [__] thing is
[__] so I'm listening recording like
you're the guy doing the one to two
stuff yeah you're like coming out there
with the one to two yelling stuff thank
you so much on stage
I get so mad at myself listening so
that's one thing it has has listening
your recordings of your set or videos
have is it do you think it's been easier
the longer you do it yeah it's torture
is it harder because I feel like when I
first started I was always I would
always like you know you get like one
room pop you're like oh I'm about to
re-listen to that five times before bed
yep no it's like I could hardly Press
Play It's hard if I don't listen to it
on the way home I'm most likely not
going to listen to it so I try my
hardest to force myself to listen to it
on the way home but I I'm not perfect I
also feel like I I have a pretty good
sense of knowing what happened
like especially a short set I know like
I'll list I really listen to feature
sets I think the more than anything
because it's like and I'll fast forward
through like moments but like I'll do
like 2x though I listen to 2x okay I
don't uh I won't do the Speedy Joe
unless something's killing I'm like
let's let's keep this two x's so funny
we get to the gist of it
and it's just me and my car that's
amazing I'm amazing
that's that's true a 2X you're seeing
like you get double the more laughs
that's hilarious dude well I I mean CJ
I'm excited for you dude and I think you
know give yourself some credit ah thanks
but you it sounds like you know what you
want to work on it's just actually doing
it instead of yeah complaining about it
and then it's just uh you know it's it's
comedy like this part is so hard for me
like like what you're just describing
obviously I complain a lot but I just
have like a I have like
it's like a it's like uh it's just it's
weird how stand-up has become like so
many things you know like it's so many
things like you gotta know how to do the
video [__] you got to do the the content
crap and then on top of that I'm just
trying to I'm just trying to really
freak out on my next five minutes
I know I mean we're you know I talked to
Fahim about it one time and he was he
had a good he had good advice where he's
like you know you can't you don't have
to figure it all out at once
but it's it's also like at the same time
it's like I don't I don't really want
the fame thing either it's like totally
not even it's not even like it's it's
really not sexy I've seen the comics
that are famous and it's kind of it is a
burden more than a a blessing I mean the
money is good I'm sure like it's fun but
like it comes with a lot of [__]
pressure responsibility and
you know what I mean yeah like I just
remember seeing like
um
I don't know it was like a good example
I guess for me like
um
I don't know Theo was a good one I saw
Theo one time like I had dinner with him
one time and and uh after like a show
and Addison Improv and just kind of like
the the VIP thing after like the show
where it's like a line and like people
are coming up to it it's probably really
cool the first time it ever happens
right the first time it ever happened
for him was probably dope as [__] people
come up to him with on their phones like
oh see bro you're my [__] buddy
oh the faking videos and selfies with
them and [__] and it's like that's
probably cool the first time but then
like dude it's after like the 30th the
40th City you're doing it and uh
it's it's a lot of like very
um
it's a lot of pressure to like I'm sure
being like funny be nice be like like
nice to them
yeah yeah and how he just like is he was
sick of it in that moment you know and
like just kind of like tired I don't
know if he's always still sick of it or
whatever but like in that moment you
could tell he was like he laid out on
stage just like to rest because you just
did two shows you did two VIP meetups
for each show so it was a line of people
taking pictures Chit Chat Small Talk the
worst thing ever and it and and you you
have to play nice and pretty much fake
you for hours
well he stopped the tour in the middle
of it yeah think of his anxiety or his
mindset right it's a lot dude and I feel
like that that is like uh the kind of
like the
that's kind of what I mean like whenever
I see that I'm like ah it doesn't look
fun I'm sure the money's good you can
make it fun I'm sure but it's like I'm
sure it just drains you you know but I
know a lot of people are doing VIP
meetups at their shows anymore
but I think I think it's just like what
I don't think of is the pressure for
sure coming up with new stuff trying to
tour and then like oh these are torn
with the same thing and you can't
tolerate the same thing you gotta come
with new [__] and all that stuff it's uh
but you're just focusing on getting good
at stand up for sure of course you sound
like you said you're worried about the
clips and all that but it's like you're
focus on getting good like I end up of
course but I know a lot that's what I'm
focusing on I'm I'm putting stuff out
here and there you know I pulled up
video sometimes I'll put up like
pictures or whatever of like my journey
and stuff but like you know try to make
that fun and funny but I mean you know
I'm I just have friends that have popped
really hard online yeah and then it and
and they're not ready and then they're
like you know what I mean but then they
but then they just take a bunch of
friends with them on the road so that
they can do a bunch of time in front of
them so they don't have to do as much
time but then what happens is you don't
make any money doing that there's not a
lot of money in stand-up I don't know if
hurt yes
if you take four guys on the road here
you're just splitting a lot of money in
hotel rooms and that and then it's that
it's not sexy at all it's like it's like
it's like that's what I'm saying it's
like not it's not like that's not why
we're doing it you know the share a
hotel room with three other dudes mm-hmm
so it's just yeah I'm trying to focus on
the right things and then hopefully
that'll add up to something else that's
what I want in my mind is a good career
well I can say that there's no right way
there's only your way CJ God I feel like
I've run five miles in my own mouth this
[__] show yo I mean we've done a lot
of these it's a lot of talks uh uh this
may this is this is one unlike any other
really yes that feels makes me feel good
it's amazing this was amazing yeah this
this may be my favorite one I think we
really got I mean I had Carlos Miller
with strippers
I mean I've seen a lot of things on this
show but you this this was real man Ah
that's real I appreciate that that's why
I was excited to have you on here
because I knew you're you're newer to
Comedy and you've seen a lot of cool
things already and you're still just
getting started so I think just keep in
mind like you're just four years dude
yeah I feel like I just keep getting
thrown in the deep end and people
yelling at me to swim yeah and you just
figure it's happening yeah it keeps on
happening whenever I was in LA I got in
really big weird situations just a year
into comedy and then the feature during
it two years in that was insane and then
now like Mothership four years in it's
just like a you know the first night I
performed at Mothership I followed Shane
Gillis oh my gosh
that's amazing so crazy it was after
like a two-hour show too it was like
everyone's like you know in their
reaction shangila's got whatever they
called it was like Eddie Murphy in the
80s dude everyone's like what what the
[__] people were like
and then and then they called mine and
by the way Tony gave me like the worst
injury he's like funny guy uh next
comment yeah CJ Lander everybody and
then like right after saying people were
like oh what the show's still huh oh man
it was like that or I was like ah yeah
um makes you stronger though oh yeah for
sure yep yeah
that's what they say it does for sure
yeah you're doing great thanks
I'm excited to do more of these and uh
keep checking in dude yeah like every
time I come to Austin we got to do one
to check in yeah let's do it make sure
you're still alive
I'm sure you haven't killed anyone make
sure I'm not back on the apps grocery
apps
hilarious dude this is amazing thanks
man I'm thanks for having me I'm glad
I'm glad this happened this was amazing
fun where um what's the best place
people to like reach out to you if they
listen to this and felt a certain type
of way and want to reach out what's the
best way for people to contact yeah
Instagram uh the CJ Landry uh some
bastard took CJ Landry uh DM him as well
tell him to delete his [__] account
I've already dmed him a bunch he's not
answering he hasn't posted since 2018
with this weird face
anyway follow me there follow me there
uh I have a podcast that's called White
trashed if you want to check that out uh
we're on YouTube and all that jazz that
was on there yeah and uh yeah uh I also
did a stand up on the spot with Jeremiah
that's on there just type in CJ Landry
on YouTube stand up on the spot yep and
that uh and then yeah if you're ever in
town in Austin uh hit me up I'll uh help
you get in the mothership if it's sold
out there's usually some standbys and
I usually help friends out get in and
stuff and um
yeah hit me up dude please I need I need
people I need support I need friends in
Austin sending positivity towards
positivity dude maybe send some [__]
five dollars yeah uh you wanna throw
your cash app out there if you got some
organic Tomatoes or something you can
send them my way some wings Maybe
well man keep up the great work CJ
you're down to something great man give
your give yourself some credit there
you're on your way appreciate it all
right I'll talk to you soon Joel
uh High breath